PAUL KINLAN: Hi, guys.
I'm Paul Kinlan, I'm a developer
advocate at Google
working on Chrome.
I've also worked on the
Web Lab project.
And we're going to talk
about it today.
So I'm with Roger and Mattias.
I keep getting your name
slightly wrong,
every single time.
So I apologize for this.
Well, yeah anyway, so these are
engineers from the project.
You're at B-Reel.
Try and give yourselves a brief
introduction, to tell
people what you do.
ROGER PALA: I'm Roger.
I'm a creative technologist at
B-Reel, and I've been the
technical leader
of the project.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL:
And I'm Mattias.
I'm also a creative
technologist, also at B-Reel.
And I've been mostly focused on
the orchestra, but that's
for another day.
PAUL KINLAN: So another time.
I was going to say save the best
for last, but they're all
equally good.
So anyway, today's
experiments.
You know what, I'll jump
back a little bit.
I'll tell everyone what
Web Lab is case it's
your first time here.
So Web Lab is a series of five
real world Chrome experiments
built at the British Science
Museum, but are also
accessible online as well.
So over the past couple of
Hangouts, we talked about some
of the other experiments, and
today we're going to talk
about Data Tracer.
Do you guys want to give a brief
overview of the Data
Tracer project?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah, so it's
a visualization of where
stuff is located on the
internet, and how fast it goes
for you to find it.
It's about finding the images.
ROGER PALA: Yeah, the whole
concept about Web Lab is
revealing kind of
like the inner
workings of the internet.
So there's things that we
usually do on the internet.
Sometimes for example, when
you look for an image in
Google search, and it
comes instantly.
Sometimes when it takes a
little bit longer you're
already a bit annoyed
about it.
And you don't really realize
that what is actually
happening behind it
is so amazing.
And it's like that is
what is happening.
It goes to a place like very,
very far away and it comes
back to you.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, I think
that's one of the things that
people on the internet--
well people on the
internet, the internet!
A lot of people don't understand
how data gets to
the machine that's
on your computer.
And the thing I like about
this project at least it
literally is the underpinnings
of the internet.
People think you can just go
straight to the machine and
pull it out.
And that doesn't
happen, right.
You don't have a direct
connection.
You have to go through one, two,
three, four, 20 different
hops just get the data back.
20 different machines on
the internet just to
get the data back.
And this is there to help
visualize that.
So this is an experiment, a
physical experiment in the
British Science Museum
and also online.
Shall we just have
a quick look.
It'd be a pretty boring Hangout
if we didn't have a
quick look.
And again my common theme.
I love these little animations
I think they're beautiful.
And they were done in Flash
originally and imported
through via Swiffy,
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yep.
PAUL KINLAN: There we go.
So every Hangout you're
going to see is me
talking about this.
[LAUGHS]
[INAUDIBLE].
So this is the is Data
Tracer project.
Do you want to kind of give us
a little understanding of
what's happening on it?
It's quite visceral.
ROGER PALA: Yeah, so here we can
see the beginning of the
generation of the world map that
we use to visualize all
the trace routes.
It is done in WebGL.
And this map is generated
dynamically.
We used a map from NASA to get
the elevation from each of the
areas of the world.
And then we tweak it a little
bit because there were some
regions that weren't
looking that nice.
PAUL KINLAN: Quite flat?
ROGER PALA: Yeah
some very flat.
PAUL KINLAN: I can imagine quite
a lot of places at sea
level where they might look
like the sea, right?
ROGER PALA: Yeah.
We had to do it this kind of
model with the sea as well.
PAUL KINLAN: This actually looks
like some of the games
I've played online quite
a while ago.
They were pretty cool.
Looks actually beautiful.
So I mean how does this directly
relate to the real
world experiment
in the museum?
Because there's a model at the
museum isn't there as well?
ROGER PALA: Yeah, so this map
was generated online using a
browser and WebGL.
Basically coding.
And then from this 3D model
generated with WebGL, we
generated--
we used [INAUDIBLE], basically,
to generate the
real map that we use
in the museum to do
some projection mapping.
PAUL KINLAN: So like the real
world map is based off the
WebGL digital representation
that you made.
ROGER PALA: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
It's a pretty big map, right?
So I take it you printed small,
was it smaller pieces
like little chunks and then kind
of assemble them up or
was it like-- would you build
Australia in one go?
ROGER PALA: I'm not
entirely sure.
This was done by our
partner Tellart.
PAUL KINLAN: Tellart.
ROGER PALA: They were in charge
of the instruments in
the museum.
All of the experiments
in the museum.
And I'm not sure, yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: It's pretty cool.
I remember seeing-- it's
huge in the museum
as well, isn't it?
ROGER PALA: It is,
it is very big.
PAUL KINLAN: We can see on the
screen now it's like four--
this a live stream and it's
relatively late at night so
there's no one there
at the moment.
Yeah, but we have four consoles
where you can kind of
select an image.
I think they're hand-selected
images aren't they, I think?
ROGER PALA: Yeah.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: I didn't want
people searching for--
well, whatever.
[LAUGHTER]
ROGER PALA: It's basically the
same experience, but using
this kind of tablet instead
of a computer.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
pretty cool.
So it's all touch sensitive
screens and stuff isn't it?
ROGER PALA: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So let's
scroll back in.
And so this is the actual Web
Lab, the visualization
that we have now.
And as we can see these blue
lines, why are they coming out
of the screen at the moment?
ROGER PALA: These are searches
from users, from other users
at the moment.
And we can see that one
interesting thing is that we
highlight Web Lab on the map.
And this is because how the
tracing works is that it needs
to always go through a server
that is located in the museum.
So when you look for an image
what we are really
tracing is not from--
so it's not from our location
in the moment.
It's always from the
science museum.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
pretty cool.
I kind of like how it all
seems to go across the
Atlantic into pretty
much New York.
You know, I think is it the
Port Authority building or
something there.
It seemed like in the late 90's
that was one of the most
connected buildings on the
internet, as well.
Pretty crazy.
I like as well how the routes
dart backwards and forwards
across the country and
a lot of the stuff's
based America it seems.
But you don't realize when
you're searching for something
where you're actually getting
the data from and how it
actually travels across.
It's pretty cool.
Oh there's an image
as well, nice.
Should we do a little search?
ROGER PALA: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: What shall
we search for?
Something British?
We haven't prepared
this beforehand.
ROGER PALA: Fish and chips.
PAUL KINLAN: Fish and chips.
That's a really good idea.
Fish and chips.
I'm going to say watch
the results come in.
They'll be the worst
results ever now.
I can't remember which one.
It's the first one,
let's have a look.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: This is
absolutely not prepared.
PAUL KINLAN: This is absolutely
not prepared, honest.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL KINLAN: So yeah, something
British we get from
England, and let's see
where the data goes.
It must be somewhere inside
the UK that we're bringing
this image from, right?
This is pretty cool.
So it's tracing the route
of the image.
Oh, interesting.
ROGER PALA: So you can see the
camera following there.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: It
goes to the States.
PAUL KINLAN: Tempe, El Segundo,
back across to
Herndon there, back
across again.
That's a pretty insane route.
I mean, I think the thing that
for me that this highlights is
that the routing system
is designed to
be resilient, right?
And which means it's not
always optimized
for the best path.
The best path route.
This actually might be the
cheapest route, cost per
carrier for instance.
I always remember doing in
like university we'd talk
about how the [? BGP ?] routed
and how all these types of
kind of routing protocols
work.
And you sometimes think it's the
quickest route from A to
B. It's not always, right?
It's like the cheapest
route sometimes.
If you've got a paid connection
with another
provider, you'll send it out
that way because it's cheaper
to send data across that link
than say another link that you
aren't paid with.
I don't know, but we don't
know whether that
happened in this case.
But it's kind of interesting
that it took 0.4 seconds to
get across 16,000 kilometers,
which is pretty cool.
And I kind of looked at the
little stats that you have.
Your trace route took 0.42
seconds to reach its
destination.
That's 400,000 times faster than
a Formula One car It just
shows you even though we're
separated by this huge expanse
of the world, essentially,
you can actually--
ROGER PALA: Access
data very easily.
Really quickly.
PAUL KINLAN: I always think it's
kind of interesting there
are some like theoretical
limits, there
is a speed of light.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: And all this
type of stuff we
can't quite get around.
But let's just turn back.
So we'll zoom out you can kind
of roughly see the path that
that was going across.
Yeah I find it kind of
quite interesting.
Some of the stuff that I
find most interesting--
which I don't know whether
this is kind
of Tellart or not--
is the traceroute protocol.
We should probably explain
traceroute, shouldn't we?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So a lot of people
watching this are
probably quite technical, and
you probably know about ping
and traceroute, these commands
that you use to assess the
network health essentially.
Ping will normally--
basically you're saying I need
to ping google.com, and then
it will fire a packet
of data, a piece of
data across to Google.
And if it doesn't reach Google,
it basically says
network unreachable, and you
know there's a problem
somewhere on the internet.
But you don't know
where, right?
You don't know whether it's any
one of those 10 hops to
get to Google, or whether it's
just your connection, or
whether it's the entirety
of Google, or
some other the service--
I probably can't say
Google too much--
is down.
And then traceroute
is designed to
complement that, right?
Traceroute sends a packet
straight across to your
server, another.com.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL KINLAN: It sends it out
to these different places.
But what it does is, it doesn't
send it straight away.
There's a thing called a
time-to-live value on each
packet of data that you send.
And this is basically to ensure
that the data doesn't--
we saw it bounce
around, right?
We sent a packet across
to get an image.
And we saw it bounce around
America a couple times before
it actually got to
the image itself.
Now there are some controls
and make sure that packet
doesn't always bounce
around the internet.
It might get stuck in some
weird loop of routing.
If like one router says, send it
that way, and then another
router says, send it back
because that's the cheapest
route to get to the network.
There's like some weird things
going across in the networks.
It's very unlikely for that
to happen, I must say.
But there's a thing called TTL
which is basically on each
packet that says how many hops
can each packet make across
the internet.
I can't remember if it's 25.
I don't know what
the default is.
Essentially if it was 25, you
could go through 25 different
routers before the packet would
just be discarded, and
said it didn't reach the host.
To cut a really long story
short, traceroute basically
sets TTL to one.
So that the first router it
reaches sends the response
back saying basically,
it reached here.
Which means that you can kind of
see the IP address that it
reached before it got canceled,
essentially.
And then once you have
that packet back, it
sets the TTL to two.
So it goes two hops down the
chain of routers, and it goes
out and out and out and out.
The point I'm trying to make is,
that's not accessible in
the browser, right?
So do you know how this
was actually--
I could have really asked this
question a lot easier.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL KINLAN: I'll have
to give some kind of
[? presentation ?] at least.
So traceroute isn't available
directly in the browser.
Do you know how this
was built?
I hope you do, otherwise--
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL KINLAN: --otherwise, I
spent 10 minutes talking about
traceroutes.
ROGER PALA: Well, Tellart
did this bit, so we
don't know the details.
But I know that they were
using Python, I think.
PAUL KINLAN: So they used
basically a Python server to
simulate traceroute--
ROGER PALA: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: --from everything
that I understand.
So how did you hook that up
into the visualization?
I mean did they do the entire
traceroute and then give you
the data back, or did they
give you kind of
one hop at a time?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: No,
it's all at once.
PAUL KINLAN: Okay.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: And just
because of cache because it's
a lot of traceroutes going
on and it takes a while.
So if millions of people are
doing it at the same time, it
would get stuck in the system.
So it's the whole thing, and
then it's cached for an hour
or something.
PAUL KINLAN: Which is probably
why fish and chips worked
quite well.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL KINLAN: That's cool.
So the point I was going
to say before was, the
visualization themselves, how do
you know where in the world
to plot them?
I mean because on traceroute
we have an IP address, and
that IP address--
ROGER PALA: So we have a system
to transform this IP
address into latitude and
longitude coordinates.
And then we just easily
place it on the map.
PAUL KINLAN:So you basically
just do a transform, kind of
put it into world coordinates,
from real world coordinates
into model world coordinates,
I suppose.
ROGER PALA: So one of the
reasons that we use the NASA
map to generate the 3D map was
because it was easy to place
in the exact location that
we were receiving the
coordinates.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
pretty cool.
Looks really nice.
I kind of like how
small the UK is.
I'm always amazed by
the size the UK.
Like the entirety of the UK
fits into California.
It's absolutely crazy.
And I could go into a long thing
about why I don't travel
anywhere in the UK.
It takes too long.
And then you go across
America, and
it's absolutely fine.
But I won't.
So that's pretty cool.
So is there anything else that
you want to kind of tell us
about this project?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: It's quite
an interesting mix, if you
look at the graphics here.
So we have the map in WebGL
running in the background, and
then the small dots here, and we
saw an image pop up and the
Web Lab is actually in 2D.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, so
the image is that
pop-up when you search?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: In 2D so that
they are interactive as
normal HTML, and we get the nice
font rendering without
doing sprites.
PAUL KINLAN: That's pretty cool
because I know, I keep
mentioning Paul Lewis.
Hello Paul.
We do recordings in the studio
sometimes and we're
two Pauls in a pod.
But I was going to say something
interesting.
Well that wasn't it.
We were talking the other day
about kind of aliasing effects
with fonts in WebGL.
Because you can never actually
position it as
accurately as you want.
You can position it accurately
in the scene, but not in user
visible space.
Essentially, it's really
hard to do text.
It's kind of interesting.
I really like it how
everything seems
to go across America.
That's insane.
Yeah, so I think we're probably
done with this one.
ROGER PALA: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So if you like this
experiment, try it out
chromeweblab.com the Data
Tracer experiment.
And also visit the museum, where
it's actually a physical
installation.
Which I'll just double click in
here again, and you'll be
able to see the live stream,
with no one there at the
moment, because it's
late at night.
Yeah, thanks guys for coming
in, by the way.
It's kind of, it is
getting late now.
It's pretty cool.
But yeah, go and see
it at the museum.
And you'll see just how it's
mapped from the real world to
what we know as the digital
world, essentially.
Cool.